[Music]
back to the Rich Eisen show not just to
our listeners and viewers but to our
friend from ESPN and being in Saturday
McMenamin how are you Dave I'm doing
well rich good to talk to you we're on
the NBA planet have I found you are you
here in Los Angeles I am I am actually
in Los Angeles these days and few and
far between I'm getting on a flight
later on the night okay at the San
Francisco for big-time ABC matchup
between the Lakers and warriors on
Saturday night for now so were you at
the you have to be this tall to ride the
ride game for the Rockets last night did
you did you visit that one great way to
describe it and I mean how about James
Harden jumping Center I have to wonder
when the last time that happened if it
even happened like do you think he was
jumping Center in high school he
probably had a guy with kind of a goofy
guy oh man one for one though right I
mean check that box yeah how about that
a bizarre you know approach to the game
just in terms of you know I'm a guy who
grew up watching basketball NBA
basketball when it was Alonzo Mourning's
in the Shaq's and Patrick Ewing and
Hakeem Olajuwon and that was the staple
of what NBA basketball is about you had
to find your marquee big man or you
didn't have a chance and you know Mike
D'Antoni kind of joked about it pregame
I asked him like had you been thinking
about doing this for years you know and
you finally did it and you think well I
kind of all dependent on how much job
security I had yeah you know my contract
right now might as well go for it you
know even lame-duck coach right now I
really could be teaming up with a
lame-duck GM you know who knows what the
fallout ultimately will be for Daryl
Morey and you know the the tweet he sent
so it was fascinating to watch the
amount of three-pointers they took it
didn't seem
obscene to me I was worried about that
you know and they put up 60 already in
this new format and I think they were in
the mid 40s last night but it was up and
down and it was switching on defense and
it was sharing the basketball and it was
Dean Russell Westbrook look like the
russell westbrook that is is fun to
watch versus the one that's kind of
makes you wince a little bit and you
know they got a good win and gets good
Lakers team yeah so I guess the
sustainability is the question but again
as you point out just last night that's
the Westbrook we've seen now that said
Harden did not have anything close to a
hardened stat line last night but you
know it's still a w against the team
that we think is gonna come out of the
West
so how sustainable do you think it is
like what would the holes be just first
blush looking at the way that need
looked last night Dave well early on
Anthony Davis was taking everything to
the rim and he ended up spraining his
right index finger and also the the
Houston defenders started funding the
post and so quite frankly the universe
and just poor entry passes thrown by
Rossana Rondo and others resulting in
turnovers and if the Rockets turn you
over that's exactly they want to do then
they get out in transition and run with
those five guys so obviously if a team
is more proficient and getting the ball
to post and their marques big man it
doesn't you know I have to get x-rays at
halftime to make sure his fingers not
broken they are really exposed in the
middle
they had no rim protection whatsoever
and you know even early on when the
Lakers were playing with a proper pace
and playing with the confidence in
attack mode like you know rajon rondo
again to the rim and finishing if
there's no one there to worry about and
you know at this stage of Rhonda's
career that's I have them too often
Dave McMenamin here on the Rich Eisen
show you surprised the Lakers didn't
make a move yesterday no I'm not
there is one sense that if you have
LeBron James on your team
the standard operating procedure has
been us do whatever you can to maximize
your team's talent to have a chance to
win it all but the deals that they
looked into just describe to me that any
time we had a chance to patch up one
hole we would spring another leak
because it was all talking about sending
out multiple pieces to receive one and
listen from LeBron James to Frank Vogel
to other members of this locker room
that they said that you know we kind of
have enough and that doesn't mean that
they're not going to see buyout market
opportunities and work out jr. Smith and
in a darren collison certainly
possibility to improve this team but you
know to me I look at the Clippers it was
a good day for them they had to feel
good about what they did but the cliff
of the Mohar clippers with Marcus Morris
I'm sorry
I think it's relatively the same team
I don't think whatever moves they made
is going to put them over the top either
they were better than the Lakers already
or they weren't Milwaukee Bucks did Pat
- because listen you have a pretty good
team you have good chemistry we don't
have to do something extreme just for
the sake of doing something on the trade
deadline day McMenamin here on the Rich
Eisen show day after the trade deadline
and you as you mentioned you're heading
up to San Francisco for a Lakers
Warriors matchup that when wound up on
the Saturday night ESPN on ABC schedule
obviously pre-season we didn't expect
the wars to be in the position that
they're in 12 and 40 with DeAngelo
Russell sent away when Andrew Wiggins
coming back walk me through that deal
and how it works for both sides that
you'll hear from the Warriors what when
you get there yeah I mean there was one
kind of sentiment that DeAngelo Russell
would finish out the season with the
Warriors because they wanted to see what
he would look like alongside
curry and just that the possibility of
if it looked great then you'd run it
back next year but obviously they found
a deal that was amenable to them because
Minnesota has been doing anything they
can obviously they wanted to get Russell
Westbrook they wanted to get handle
Russell last summer before he ended up
being traded to the Warriors because of
his you know great friendship across
eight hounds and they figure that's
going to be their small big combo to
last them for years but they traded for
Russell to begin with just so they
didn't completely lose come Durant for
nothing and so at the end of the day
you're just moving a piece and continue
to assure that you didn't lose Kevin
Durant for nothing and you get Andrew
Wiggins who some people around the
league still believe in I do I think he
hasn't had a ton structure in Minnesota
and you put them in one of the best runs
organizations with one of the best
coaches one of the best front office's
and the Warriors you can kind of limit
his menu and you can do certain things
really well for you and you get a
first-round draft pick out of it I think
it's a really smart move by the Warriors
not that I don't believe in D'Angelo
Russell but you know sometimes you have
to give up something to get something
and overall I'm really excited to see
what the Warriors look like next year
with the healthy clay healthy step frame
on in there Wiggins in there and
whatever their traffic ends up being for
this tank season yeah I mean you could
make a case Dave that um the trade
deadline didn't appreciably approve
improve anybody's chances to win the NBA
championship this June but it certainly
improved the Warriors chances to win it
to June's from now when you say like
that's that that might be the the one
trade that does affect a championship
moment that that anybody made yesterday
if you had to lay odds on that trade can
bring a championship to somebody right
would you say unless I'm wrong yeah I'm
with you I think the only other team you
would say
for this next four or five months any
team that put themself into the
conversation would be what Miami did the
heat and maybe they yeah they had Andrew
budala former Finals MVP who you know
has all the playoff experience in the
world a switchable defender a smart
leader who you know still showed like he
had something left in the tank last year
through the Warriors postseason run you
add another strong wing defender in a
Jai Crowder and you already had you know
a very strong season going for you with
you know some some young shooters like
Tyler Hiro and Kendrick none and Tucker
Robinson making the threes and Jimmy
Butler being a leader and amaz bio being
perhaps the most improved player in the
league
Miami I'd say with the one team that
kind of went from a classification of no
probably win around or two in the
playoffs to it wouldn't shock me if they
were the Eastern Conference
representative of the NBA Finals really
I mean over the Bucks too huh I mean it
just seems to me that Milwaukee's just
so head and shoulders above and and
we'll see who gives him the best shot in
an Eastern Conference final but then
again I'm not the ending I'm not the
insider that you are Dave they are
they're so strong defensively and the
honest that will most likely be
back-to-back MVP but right yeah a lot of
this leagues comes down to like the best
talent best collection of talent right
and the more his great system but when
you break things down in a seven-game
series do you want to rely on Eric
Bledsoe Chris Middleton you know I think
Miami might be able to say that they
have the the overall collection of
talent to match what Milwaukee yes so
that would say are you saying that it's
entirely possible that the team that was
standing between LeBron and a
championship in Los Angeles is the team
that he created a super team four years
ago that would be quite a storyline
wouldn't it wouldn't it be yeah I had
some conversations
yesterday and you know maybe this is me
thirsting for the story but he already
got the one championship in Cleveland
that kind of counts as in some people's
eyes maybe like a championship and a
half because of all the extra that went
into it if he could beat his former team
he Pat Riley who you know LeBron I did
it to me into the 2016 championship the
Pat Riley and others in the heat
organization told him he was making the
biggest mistake of his career by leaving
the heat at that point to go back to
Cleveland and that would be that'd be
something not sure would be last one for
did you hear Charles say that the Sixers
were the Cleveland Browns in the NBA did
you hear that one yeah I mean good money
man he makes us laugh he makes us think
I could kind of understand what he's
saying like a like a huge collection of
talent that everybody looks into it and
says that's championship quality and
when actual execution of it happens
there they they don't I mean being ten
games above 500 right now as a six seed
is not akin to I guess the the two and
six team at the the Browns were at the
halfway point this year but I can kind
of pick up what he's putting down Dave
would you agree yeah I mean I I do agree
the Sixers were you know they make us
two preseason predictions and you know I
don't know that there's I don't know
about that overall exercise to begin
with but I did pick the Sixers because I
liked what I saw them I was a playoffs
last year another loss Jimmy Butler and
JJ Redick but you know Joel embiid
when he's right is the most dominant
player on the court in any game he plays
they were one bounce fall on the rim
away from making Eastern Conference
Finals but and beat hasn't been good
this year he put himself out there to
start the year said he wants to an MVP
wants to win Defensive Player of the
Year and he's taken a step back in his
overall production Ben Simmons says look
good but mostly good when embiid isn't
in there I like what they did the
deadline is Len Robinson's to me is a
player that can
help them alec burks I'm not so sure
he's gonna do much he's more of a name
and who put up some numbers in Utah
years ago so people still think he's a
guy who's productive but I don't really
put him in that category but I don't
know I think Brett Brown has a tough job
and we know what happened with the
Browns who ultimately took the fall for
that collection now Freddie kitchens and
I think Brett Brown even though he got
an extension this past offseason he
certainly has a itself a couple months
ahead of him because the expectation
remains with with that group you have if
there are ill-fitting parts and if there
isn't the type of shooting that they had
for years the expectation is to get them
in Eastern Conference Finals Dave
appreciate the time man I'll always
appreciate you coming on the show and I
like your insight so thanks so much and
have a safe flight up to San Francisco
yes accurate you got it at MC ten on
Twitter for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app